folks we have all suffered through one
terrible meta or another a meta is how a
game is played at the highest
competitive level when players pick the
best strategies and pit them against
each other the meta is supposed to be
balanced but sometimes things slip
through the cracks whether it's a broken
item or an insanely overpowered
character something goes wrong and turns
a good meta into a broken one so today
we wanted to run down the worst metas
we've ever seen here are the top 10 most
broken metas in eSports history kicking
off our list is CS gos most recent
shitty meta the reign of the creep and
the creek just so strong oh my word
maybe too strong Harry that is
unbelievable from golden what around
four months in 2018 and 2019 csgo
players were terrorized by the aw but as
soon as valve fixed that problem they
created another and gave rise to the
Krieg meta another one vs. - reloaded
you spots the shoulder and he doesn't
bail out of the fight baits out the
shots at Nick's convinced he's got that
shot he's got it through the smoke no
idea by November 2019 it was the most
popular weapon in pro play even after
bowel jacked up the price again Holden
having to do it all from the back of the
site well it had a hundred-percent armor
penetration a high rate of fire a scope
it was relatively cheap had great range
and insane first shot accuracy simply
put it outclassed every other gun in the
game at a point where you are two rounds
away from victory man showing his
prowess to taps with the Krieg he's
looking for one of the most brutal aces
that we've seen in recent memory oh that
looks so easy 24 16 oh my god the nerf
is coming boys eventually community
outrage got the creek nerfed in April
2020 letting into one of CS gos most
frustrating eras number 9 on our list is
a meta that turned Street Fighter into
sleep
fighter Wow attack and healing that's
the demoralize er with the release of
Ultra Street Fighter 4 came Elena
now capoeira fighter with an ultra that
could healer after she's took enough of
the image to build it up where's my
number one right here at the booth Elena
obviously everyone hates his character
with Elena in the mix matches could last
forever she had a simple loop play
defensively take a bit of damage and
heal right back up usually taking the
lifely if you took any damage
awesome I just meant you were closer to
healing again fully stocked he's going
right at it and only a scam strong
honest any you guys are likely now with
that
it was incredibly frustrating to play
against and many saw it as extremely
boring to watch coming in at number
eight is one of the shortest but most
frustrating metas in cs:go history the
release of the r8 revolver with a
[ __ ] pistol why is that allowed the
RA it was incredibly overpowered when it
was added to the game in the 2015 winter
update it was cheap and could one-shot a
player at close range with a body shot
it was a pocket nuke and for just a
couple of days it straight-up broke the
game oh yeah one shots in the stomach
yeah this is going to be so insane be
[ __ ] over bar
this guy this meta may not have lasted
as long as some of our other entries but
it was so unbearably frustrating that
csgo fans will never forget it taking
the number seven spot on our list is the
meta that devastated world's 2017 the
ardent sensor meta everybody's just on
the race to ardent sensor because first
support to get arted sensor if you can
get an entire back before the other
support then that could turn into a
tower a dragon you know in first
rotation during season seven Brian
decided that they wanted to make ardent
sensor a more viable support item and by
Worlds it was definitely more viable
targets that were healed or shielded by
an ardent support got bonus attack speed
on hit magic damage and on hit healing
lots of it
in a track
[Applause]
Arden sensor led to long drawn-out
defensive games and boring support picks
that brainlessly spam buffs on their ad
carry
sir is hungry nine stacks no champions
that he's looking for some dinner three
to three care team w/e feather storm
mystic cosmic radiance on the Bryant may
have nerfed it after that world's but it
was still one of the slowest met as the
game has ever seen during its most
important tournament of the year
Starcraft 2 is a game about strategy and
game sense macro and micro but what
happens when you throw all that away and
instead resort to one simple comp well
you get the number six entry on our list
the brood Lord investor meta well
parties losing this base that oh my god
I can't even oh my god sorry guys that
we called that alright
normally when you're on two bases with
dirty it's a three base Protoss that has
better upgrades and more tech normally
that doesn't go out but the main culprit
here was the infestors fungal growth
which when paired with brutal ings could
easily wipe out many of the most common
units in the game and he's doing a great
job look how many investors are here
Wow the closet was so elegance those
roaches yeah and he wants to get these
rulers reading Mike rebec very well
great bumbles going off by Yugi oh and
look at this this destroyed Starcraft's
balance because there was only ever one
correct way to play make root Awards and
investors will you be able to break
through the corrupters are nowhere to be
seen
now if you come out of these scary and
all those investors they have too much
energy and now suddenly this fight bus
can't even a technical on fight he lost
those are gone he tries to blink around
he gets bungle if the person would be
the end of this game the stalkers are
getting eliminated here he's got to call
off this last Colossus though and he
does and so those certain what the hell
is happening here
this is actually Jesus man I I tell you
party really thought he was gonna win
guys like somehow riot keeps breaking
their game just in time for world the
juggernaut patch is probably the most
broken Pro meta in league history and
that's why it's coming in at number five
on our list
going into worlds 2015 ride decided a
couple of champions were juggernauts now
and just gave them insane overpowered
buffs various gangplank and mordekaiser
were hilariously broken with gangplank
even sporting an unheard-of 100% pick
ban and win raped jordan steals the kill
away as is his right at the mordekaiser
player big engage from can sing knocks
up three and the dragon is still chasing
the enemy ad carry Lord's got to be
careful kill the dragon value is big on
this one all is well
there's a triple kill they're going for
four right clean things up after worlds
and apologize for implementing such
drastic changes before a major event but
no one will ever forget the mess that
was a juggernaut meta on the game's
biggest stage
comes across he gets some damage on this
day
[Applause]
number four on our list is a time when
all you ever heard in every dota 2 match
was this that's right we're talking
about the ho ho haha meta sniper
shrapnel got buffed in passion 6.83
and after that his infamous voice line
haunted dota players everywhere now
they're gonna jump in ax calls this edge
trouble
next up goodbye got a buyback call comes
in mic gets blown up by swittel sizzle
going right on his he friggin pops the
ghost scepter stays alive but another
threat no ghost
they're holding 4 vs. 5 one mic no
sniper had a brain-dead kit to begin
with and his new buffs allowed him to
turn dota 2 into another game entirely
he's walking right in he'll pop the mat
to style it gets X up get a head to the
trees earthquake connects still in there
now the big call Mike turning it around
Cecil doesn't a punk he doesn't have my
back
this is now at trouble as well and
there's no fire bags for real
nobody is buyback well it's up at 11
swindle hits a triple kill to make
matters worse troll warlord was also
stupidly over to turning him into a raid
boss who mini stuns his enemies into a
Bolivian sniper fur relic and sleazo his
troll warlord it's not dota with one or
both of these heroes right has to
retreat back into the base pile I die
not gonna make it this time he goes down
and a big heal flies outs liesl barely
alive on his troll moving forward and
repelled he could get black they call GG
it's over 25 minutes
thankfully my frog stepped in to save us
from the hell that dota had become but
it took him months to fix things meaning
to that terrible laugh still echoes and
dota players minds to this day number 3
on our list is lions debut and Rainbow
six siege which introduced a meta that
almost destroyed the game as we knew it
Raphael using the smoke and Candela
combo is just going to push right in
they'll have some covering fire as the
artillery of glass stands
and look at that Raphael they will just
bully the vitality sweeps into the site
when wine was first released his gadget
the EE 1d allowed him to skin defenders
through walls revealing their location
it gave players a stupidly easy counter
to pre and post plant rotation the game
breaking info that line provided to his
team left the game in a disastrous state
and he tore high level siege apart for
months easily when season 9 rolled
around it'll be something ounce that
line was a band from Pro play while they
reworked them into something less broken
finally bringing an end to one of sieges
most infamous eras the runner-up spot on
our list goes to the meta that broke
overwatch goats chat I cannot imagine
what it's like to be a pro player right
now cha-cha-cha I want you to think of
this okay in pro players scrim this meta
probably six to eight hours a day it all
started just after Brigitta was released
when an na open division team named
goats realized that playing three tanks
and three supports could basically win
any game drew has now fallen and it's
gonna be white ain't going on over and
now they're gonna get all these stack of
kills as they're hunting them down this
is just all going downhill or crossing
out and goats will be able to capture it
with six minutes and 29 seconds left on
the clock
that was a massacre eventually the Khan
made its way into the overwatch League
which is when Blizzard started to get a
real idea of how much the community
hated this meta we do see that the
outlaws are gonna pull out Dante's
tracer this has been
some of the things I also have been
waiting for is a good tracer player on
Houston it's Jake on the forest combos
worked well for them before but as soon
as they see the defensive setup they
will just simply swap it away crucial
time lost here for the outlaws well you
know you want your team to win right
they're gonna have to play what's better
viewership declined while numerous
patches tried and failed to kill it
including an entire character designed
to counter it but worst of all the most
popular role in the game the image was
hardly being played for over a year
hey you guys want to go goats eventually
Blizzard threw in the towel and at the
cost of pretty much all creativity and
hero picks they introduced two two to
roll lock changing how we play overwatch
forever the worst meta in eSports
history goes to the character that
single-handedly killed her own game
smash 4 is Bayonetta some brief
excitement for her release it didn't
take long for the smash community to
realize just how broken she was one more
stop chant is out
I never chant that against the Bayonetta
player because you see that get turned
on your head with extremely fast
movement a strong recovery and a
OneTouch kill combo from anywhere on
screen Bayonetta had almost no
weaknesses even after she got nerfed
there was no stopping her torment it got
so bad that the community not only hated
the character but started hating the
people who played her to it what a catch
some captain Zack oh that's look if you
got to be the villain you might as well
play the part well in the end the only
thing that could stop Bayonetta was an
entirely new game but we'll never forget
her reign of terror in Smash 4 alright
folks that's our list those are the
worst meadows of all time but hey if
there's a meta that you think we missed
something you're still salty about let
us know in the comments don't forget to
sub to the channel and pay this is the
new meta but you've got to follow us on
Twitch now too you never want to miss
one of my live streams thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week
what's the worst video you've ever
experienced Brendan Oh something that
was really bad for like people of my
rank is double shields I feel like the
worst meta I've ever experienced it's
not on this list is Street Fighter 4
Arcade Edition err a Yun he has a punch
where he leaps halfway across the screen
and punches you in the face and before
if you've walked it he would be - which
meant he wasn't allowed to press the
buttons afterwards but now he was Plus
which means he was a lot to press
buttons afterwards oh my god [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the worst part was that Street
Fighter 4 had not so great online and so
there would just be these moments
sometime
Riaan would just be would have just
spent apart to teleport in front of your
face and there was nothing you could
literally nothing you can do about it